Mir ist langweilig.
Ich habe keine Freunde hier und
die Stadt kenne ich auch nicht.
Vielleicht sollte ich es mal
mit dieser App versuchen.
Da kann ich bestimmt jemanden
kennenlernen, der hier in der Nähe wohnt.
Ich öffne die App einfach mal
und lasse mich überraschen.
Mal schauen, was es hier so gibt.
Oh, der sieht ein wenig zu seriös aus.
Ich glaube, dieser Herr würde lieberGeschäftspläne schreiben, als spazieren zu gehen.
Mhm, der ist wohl ein bisschen zu alt.
Naja, ich finde ihn sympathisch.
Er isst wohl sehr gerne.
Sieht nett aus, trotz Übergewicht,
aber ich gucke noch weiter.
Ich denke, dieser Typ wohnt auf einem Bauernhof.
Ich mag Tiere sehr gerne.
Oh, er mag wohl die Farbe Rot, genau wie ich.
Ich glaube, mit ihm kann man
Spaß haben. Lustiger Typ.
Ihm schreibe ich sicher nicht.
Mit der Waffe in der Hand und dem Gesichtstuch
sieht er ganz schön gefährlich aus.
Er ist ziemlich muskulös.
Ich denke, er verbringt viel Zeit im Fitnesscenter oder
zu Hause beim Hantelheben.
Er ist genau das Gegenteil von dem vorherigen Typ.
Er sitzt sicher den ganzen
Tag am Computer und zockt.
Oh, dieser Junge sieht sehr jung aus.
Wir sind
wohl aus sehr verschiedenen Altersklassen.
Er ist noch ein Kind.
Ohh, da ist ja Raphael aus meiner Deutschklasse.
Er hat ein tolles Bild.
Raphael habe ich bereits kennengelernt, aber
vergessen, nach seiner Nummer zu fragen.
Ich schreibe ihm am besten gleich hier in
dieser App und frage ihn nach seiner Nummer.
Hallo Raphael.
Ich bin Nola aus deiner Deutschklasse.
Oh, er hat sofort zurückgeschrieben.
Vielleicht ist ihm ja auch gerade langweilig …
Oh, ja hallo Nola!
Wir haben vergessen, die Nummern auszutauschen.
Oh, ja super, dass du mir schreibst!
Super, dass ich dich hier gleich gefunden habe.
Meine Nummer wäre: 007 79 456
789. Ruf mich doch gleich an.
Telefonieren ist einfacher als
das Hin-und-her-Geschreibe.
Ich rufe ihn an.
Warum sagt mir die Stimme, der gewünschte
Mobilteilnehmer konnte nicht erreicht werden?
Ah, ich habe eine Zahl falsch eingegeben.
Ich versuche es gleich nochmals.
Hallo Raphael! Ich bin's, Nola.
Danke für deine Nummer.
Hallo Nola! Kein Ding, spätestens das nächste Mal,wenn wir uns gesehen hätten,
hätte ich sie dir geben können.
Mir war grad langweilig, darum habe ich mich auf
der App umgesehen und bin dann auf dich gestoßen.
Ich habe dir dann auch gleich geschrieben.
Naja, normalerweise frage ich die Frauen
nach ihrer Nummer und nicht umgekehrt.
Aber schön, den Feminismus mal
von einer anderen Seite zu sehen.
Das hat doch nichts mit Feminismus zu tun!
Ich mache doch nur Spaß.
Hättest du Lust, morgen etwas zu unternehmen?
Es sollte schönes Wetter sein.
Ja, sehr gerne. Wir könnten ja
gemeinsam in die Stadt gehen.
Genau, ich kann dir die Stadt
und auch tolle Plätze zeigen.
Falls du Tiere magst, könnten wir auch in
den Zoo oder auf einen Bauernhof gehen.
Ich mag Tiere sehr gerne! Eine tolle Idee.
Wollen wir uns morgen treffen
und dann spontan entscheiden?
Das klingt doch super!
Treffen wir uns nach dem Mittag
an der Bushaltestelle beim Park?
Ja, perfekt! Dann bis morgen,
Raphael, ich freue mich.
Toll, ich mich auch. Mach's gut!
Raphael ist echt nett.
Ich freue mich, mit ihm
morgen die Stadt zu erkunden.
Aber heute sollte ich mal meine Kisten auspacken.
Sonst stehen die noch lange hier.
Da ist noch echt viel Zeug drin.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wohin mit den Sachen.
Ich lege einfach alles zusammen in
einen Raum, wo es mich nicht stört.
Dann kann ich es später einräumen.
Mist, ich sehe gar nichts mehr so.
Ich falle bestimmt, wenn ich
es so versuche zu tragen.
Es ist auch viel zu schwer so.
Ich lasse es doch lieber erst einmal
hier und räume es besser hier aus.
Was habe ich denn alles hier drin?
Wieso klingelt mein Handy jetzt?
Anscheinend habe ich Nachrichten von
den Personen aus der App bekommen.
Ich schaue sie mir einfach mal an.
Ich kann ja nichts verlieren.
Hallo Nola, ich kann nicht nur gut
Kühe melken. Schreibe mir doch.
Ich suche noch meine neue Bonnie. Gruss Clyde.
Ich würde gerne auf was anderem
rumtippen als nur auf meiner Tastatur.
Ich glaube, diese App lösche ich gleich wieder.
Das nächste Mal, wenn ich Freunde
suche, gehe ich lieber nach draußen.
Im Internet kann man sich nie sicher sein,
wer sich hinter einem Profil verbirgt.
Möchtest du einen kostenlosen online Deutschkurs machen?
Bei uns kannst du dein Deutschniveau wählen.
So lernst du Deutsch Lektion für Lektion in der richtigen Progression.
Deutsch lernen mit Spass!
Besuche jetzt unseren Kanal "Hallo Deutschschule"
Möchtest du noch weitere Videos sehen? Dann abonniere unseren Kanal. Jeden Sonntag ein neues Video!